the stock market is absolutely bonkers
in 70 days of the 249 trading days of
the year we've hit an all-time high
that's right the s p 500 keeps hitting
all-time high after all-time high after
all-time high why it's because the
market is completely manipulated there
is no rationality to what we're seeing
happen here so when we go ahead and we
look at the actual performance 70 of the
249 trading days so far this year s p
500 all-time high that is 28
of all trading days we have hit an
all-time high literally one out of every
four days or so all-time high all-time
high all-time high this is insane we go
ahead and we look at it on a chart
there's little dips along the way but
baby oh baby oh baby we are just going
up and to the right and nobody can stop
us if we go ahead and we look
historically at the actual stock market
performance what we can see here charlie
bolillo
coming in hot with the actual charts you
can see that 1929 there was 45 trading
days where we hit an all-time high and
then from 1930 until 1953
we did not hit another all-time high
from 1930 to 1953 23 years straight no
all-time highs in the s p 500 and then
again we had stretches like in 1974 to
1979 or 2001 until 2007. there was no
all-time highs so there have been these
record levels of no all-time highs at
the same time there have been times
where there are all-time highs year
after year after year after year like in
1989 until 2000 every single year for 11
years we hit all-time highs well every
single year since 2013 we have hit an
all-time high in fact in 2017 we had 62
all-time highs in 2021 we now just today
hit number 70. 70 times this year we've
hit an all-time high though most that
we've ever hit outside of 1995 in 1995
we hit 77 all-time highs so since 1929
until today this year we have hit the
second most all-time highs in the s p
500 in history or until 1929 that is
absolutely bonkers when you start to
look at it and so the last five years of
the s p 500 returns here from ben
carlson is real simple to see 2017 up 21
2018 down four 2019 up 31 up 18 and then
up 28
these are historical type returns or
basically one bad year from the late
1990s dot-com run what you saw 95 up 37
96 up 22 97 up 33 98 up 28 and 1990 nine
was up 20
stocks only go up why do stocks only go
up it's because we have intervention in
the market there is no free market we
have the central banks and politicians
continue to stick their little sticky
fingers into the market continue to
manipulate interest rates lower and they
continue to print and print and print
they stick liquidity in every exotic
corner of the market they simply have
outlawed bear markets and they have
banned market corrections if stocks look
like they're gonna start to fall all of
a sudden here comes the monetary
stimulus we have a society that is
completely addicted to monetary stimulus
if they stop the market will crash and
people will lose a lot of money if they
raise interest rates too quickly or too
severely we will actually bankrupt the
united states we won't be able to
service our debt and so ultimately what
we have is central bankers and
politicians that are backed in a corner
they can't stop with the monetary
debasement they have to keep interest
rates artificially low they have to
continue the quantitative easing
programs and therefore what they are
doing is they are devaluing the currency
when you devalue the currency you pump
asset prices higher and so stocks
literally cannot go down for long
periods of time because the currency
will only continue to be devalued we can
go all the way back to middle school
math with fractions literally it is a
fraction you have an asset and it is
denominated in a currency if you devalue
the currency then the price of that
asset continues to go up it's simple
math and stocks will never ever ever go
down for long periods of time because
the currency will never stop being
devalued